INSTRUCTOR: Hey, everyone.
Welcome back.
In today's video, I want to talk
to you about another high level
topic.
And I promise we'll get into
kind of the meat of cloud
computing as soon as possible.
But I think this is an
interesting one to discuss.
Kind of one of the big
reasons, arguably, I
would say the biggest reason why
people and technologists love
to leverage cloud
infrastructure,
and that's primarily because
it is a set of resources
globally available
that we can kind of tap
into at the click of a button.
And so understanding how that
structure is really important
to know what and when to
use these different tools
and resources.
So I'll stop blabbering on about
it and just kind of dive right
into it.
Again, hopefully
it's a quick one,
but I think, again, it's
still very relevant.
So, first off, just kind of
think about some of the threats
that data companies, online
companies, in general, face.
Obviously leaks,
hacks, latency, right?
So how long it takes
for me to load an app
or load a website, running
out of resources, the capacity
itself.
If my server gets knocked out.
We've talked about some
of these different things.
Accidental deletion
of data, right?
You hire on an intern,
they're new to this.
They accidentally
delete everything.
All these things are real
risks that companies face.
And by leveraging kind of the
geographic effects of having
multiple servers across
different locations
with automatic backups
and redundancy,
you start to at least, I won't
say completely get rid of,
but mitigate some of the
issues associated with these.
I
Can remove the effect
or I can isolate regions
so that maybe a leak or
a hack in one location
isn't affecting my
data in another region
or my backup in another region.
I can ensure that I have
resources close to my users
to reduce that latency.
I can have limitless
capacity, effectively, right?
I can just continue to use
these economies of scale.
I can ensure that bad
weather in one location
can't hit the
other data centers.
All these different
things are enabled
by leveraging kind of
these geographic effects
of these large cloud providers.
So as a concrete
example of this,
think about Crumbl Cookies.
It's a Logan company
or started in Logan,
not that long ago, 2017.
And in that short
amount of time now,
they have a Crumbl location
in every state, all 50 states,
Alaska and Hawaii included.
If you take the classic model,
kind of precloud computing
model, Crumbl has an app
where you go on there,
you select your cookies,
and you hit send.
And they grab your
cookies, put them in a box,
and then a driver will
drive them to your location.
Well, that's a lot
of coordination.
That's a lot of internet
traffic that has to happen.
I send a request from my phone.
I pull up the Crumbl app.
I send a request that is
coming through my home network,
going through whatever channels,
or whatever kind of networking
infrastructure is in
my local area, that
is going to have to
go to Crumbl servers.
Now, that's the question,
is where is that server?
There's going to be latency
if it's very far away.
Again, imagine we have
one server in Logan
that is the app server
for all of Crumbl Cookies.
Well, then I'm in
Anchorage, Alaska,
and I want Crumbl
Cookies, my request
has to travel from my home,
through my local network,
across some sort of either,
satellite connection
or high speed Lan network,
whatever the networking
infrastructure looks like
between those locations,
to get all the way to Logan.
So great.
OK, I've got that now.
So I get the request
in Logan, process it.
Then I need to send it back
over the same channels,
back to the Crumbl location
in Anchorage, Alaska, to say,
hey, the cookies or
this is the person
in this location
wants these cookies.
Here's the order.
Then in Anchorage, Alaska, they
have to send a request back
to say, OK, order confirmed.
And then every time we want
to do any sort of update
on time to deliver or
anything like that,
that's all going over that
same long distance network.
That's OK, maybe?
But, again, as you can see, I
pulled some numbers and rough--
again, this is back of
the envelope calculations,
going to be around
200 milliseconds.
Which doesn't sound
that slow, but I
want you to try to
think about, and maybe
time, how long a typical
web page takes to load,
and you'd be surprised how long
200 milliseconds feels like.
But even more importantly,
the cost associated with that.
I now have to worry that if the
networking infrastructure is
expensive across
these locations, now
I'm paying higher
premiums because I'm just
having to constantly transport
information back and forth.
But maybe that's not
even that big of a deal.
But, as we said before, what if
there is a bad storm in Logan
that all of a sudden
knocks out our power lines?
Well, then it's not just the
Logan Crumbl Cookies that
are kind of hindered by that.
It would technically be
every Crumbl Cookies.
And so you can start.
To see that really having
these multiple, different data
centers that kind
of host or serve
your content or your
resource or your users
can be really critical for
just a variety of reasons.
So in the context
of AWS, again, this
is kind of AWS
specific verbiage,
but take it to
any cloud platform
and they have something similar.
They're all structured
roughly the same.
They just will use their
different branding.
So AWS defines everything
in the context of regions.
And you saw this
when you or when
we talked in some
of the last videos
about kind of opening
up your AWS console
and you can see the region
in the top right hand corner.
This is what we're
talking about.
This is the high
level kind of location
of resources you want to
use, that you get to select.
You can, in some cases, and
we'll see those specific ones,
select down to the level
of an availability zone.
So within a region,
that's kind of a big area.
That's what these dots are
showing on the map here.
These are AWS regions
with the first one
being northern Virginia,
that was launched in 2006.
So regions, within
regions, there's
going to be multiple
availability zones.
I think there's at least
two in every region.
But some have multiple,
especially the bigger regions.
And then within each
availability zone,
there's going to
be data centers.
So the region gives us a
rough geographical location,
and we'll talk about
it a little bit, why
we don't get exact locations.
But it'll give us a rough
geographic location of, hey,
the servers are over here.
And then within
that we are going
to have multiple availability
zones, which these are then
going to have different
resources or access or latency
potentially, even.
And then within each of
these availability zones,
we'll have multiple
data centers.
The data centers, the
actual physical building.
Everything else above
that is an abstraction.
But we can never get down
to the level of data centers
or selecting data centers.
Again, that information is
typically kept very private,
of what the, or where exactly
those data centers are.
So we typically only worry
about the region level,
but it's important to know
that there are some underlying
things.
And, again, we will
see occasionally
where we can select the
availability zone of our choice.
Other things, regions are
isolated from one another.
So they are going to be--
you can kind of see, I mean,
they look close together,
but broadly speaking, these
are kind of logically isolated
assets or resources.
I believe there is high
speed network connections
between different regions so
that they can transfer data
quickly and cheaply.
But, yeah, so communication
between regions,
uses AWS backbone network.
I already said that.
User content-- or
better said, we
can control any data replication
across regions as well too.
So if, for example,
I have data that's
stored in the northern
Virginia region,
I could replicate
it and force it
to be stored in Oregon, for
example, or the US west two
region, which is broadly
listed as Oregon.
And so if I want to
ensure that they're
kind of on opposite
sides of the country,
again, really isolated from
one another, I can do that.
There are some special
regions as well, too,
that we're never going to use.
You'll know if you use
these or need to use these.
There's a China region,
at least as of right now,
there's a China region.
There are two China
regions, I believe.
Yeah, Beijing and Ningxia.
These are isolated from kind of
the broader internet network.
So, for example, if
you have an application
you're deploying
in China, you'll
need to use something
like AWS China region
because that's going
to logically isolate it
from other resources
that are not
permitted to be used in there.
Kind of similar to that,
actually, is the AWS gov cloud.
So this is a so it's for
confidential, unclassified
information, so CUI,
CUI as that designation.
So anything that is
at that level or below
can leverage as far as
security level or access level.
Anything at CUI
or below could be
or could leverage AWS gov cloud.
Sorry, it's a mouthful.
But either way, that allows
US government agencies
to kind of do their
work in the cloud.
Having come from
this space, that
is a really, really valuable
resource for the same reason
that every other tech company
wants to use cloud resources.
The government and
government contractors
can benefit from them as well.
And so being able to have
a place where you can use
or kind of leverage
the fact that you
need a secure environment
to work in, but still
in the cloud with all
the scalable resources
and everything, is
really valuable.
And then there's less
information on these publicly,
but there are,
seemingly there are
two top secret regions so that
are at the top secret level.
These, seemingly, are separated
by a very large distance,
multiple availability zones,
just as we seen before.
And, again, they are designed
to very heavily mitigate
all the risks, not just
environmental risk,
realistically, but every
risk possible because it
is such sensitive information
that's leveraging that.
It's just important to know
that there are these restricted
access regions.
You're not just going
to be able to select
them, one click button,
use these different regions
in the cloud.
But if you need them,
they are available.
So it's nice to
see as a resource.
So, yeah, really, I would
say like the main things
to consider is if you
want to or when you're
selecting a region,
for us, in this class,
it's probably just going to
be whatever one you want to.
I typically, again, as I've said
before, prefer to choose one
closest to me.
If you hit up this
website here, CloudPing.
Let me just pull that up here,
you can see and run this,
click this button
HTTP ping, and it'll
ping the distance to different
cloud servers or regions, better
statement.
So you can see kind of the
latency in your location.
So I'm here on my home
network in Logan right now.
This is the latency between me
and these different regions.
So 74 milliseconds to
the Virginia region.
My lowest time here is
to the California region.
Not too surprising, right,
or the Oregon region.
Both of these are
relatively close to us here.
So 52 milliseconds,
62 milliseconds.
And you can see that there's
a bunch of other ones as well.
All the EU ones.
And you can see this gets to
really be far away or long
times, long latencies.
All the Asian regions.
And then actually, yeah,
you can see the gov cloud.
So you can see the one
that's at the CUI level
and that's the US gov west
one is pretty close to us.
And they have other cloud
platforms as well too.
So if you're using Digital
Ocean, Core Weave, Google cloud,
as we've talked about
before, all of these
have different regions.
So you can see they all
function roughly the same,
but just something to note.
So, yeah, latency is
probably the main reason
I choose different
regions right now.
But know, as well, if there
are any kind of data governance
or legal requirements,
for example,
again, sometimes you
can't move data outside
of geographical boundaries.
Maybe we can't move
data outside of the US.
So I know that that's
going to define
the set of regions I can use.
Or, similarly, maybe
some state laws
that say, hey, if this protected
information is being stored,
it has to be it, has to
stay within the state
borders or something like that.
Services can also drive that.
So some services aren't
available in every region.
The main four US ones have
pretty much every resource
that you could want, so it's
not really a big issue for us.
And then cost, as well, too.
So as you start to get
to scale, right, you're
spinning up a ton
of resources, then
you might want to really
look at this as well too.
Because it might
be something where,
hey, if I'm willing to have
a little bit of latency,
I can push this over to this
lower utilization region
and, therefore, lower my costs.
And, as we said,
outside of the--
or we have regions
that we can select.
Within each region we have
multiple availability zones.
And then each one of
those availability zones
is going to be isolated,
kind of partitioned.
So these aren't going to--
They're going to
have, again, kind
of some sort of logical
or physical isolation
between each other.
So these availability zones
are going to basically house
data centers.
Data centers will have really,
really fast connections
between each other.
The availability zones
might have kind of some--
Yeah so they have
their high speed
kind of networking between them,
but they are kind of separated
logically.
So, again, this is
why I say it's, it's
more of an abstraction of it.
The data centers are the
actual physical buildings.
The availability
zones are just a kind
of logical isolation of
a set of data centers
that then, between
availability zones,
you have high speed networking
to allow for easy data
transfer between
the availability
zones, but not
quite as fast as you
would get between data centers.
So you can basically imagine is
like I'm selecting availability
zone and I'm expecting kind of
the fastest speeds within there.
Any transfer or
kind of manipulation
within that availability
zone will be really fast.
If I'm duplicating across
availability zones,
it might be a little
slower, but not as slow
as going between regions, if you
want to think about it that way.
So, yeah, they'll recommend and
you'll see this a lot of times
that they'll ask,
hey, do you want
to replicate this
one button click
across multiple
availability zones?
You can do that where necessary.
Sometimes there's a
cost associated with it,
or oftentimes there are.
Sometimes there's not, though.
And yeah, you can choose
availability zones
in a lot of cases.
Again, at the high
level, though, we're
only seeing the regions when
we click that little dropdown
menu on the top right, but
then within specific resources
you'll see the ability to
select an availability zone.
And then, yeah, down to
the data center level,
this is kind of the finest
grain, isolation of kind
of large scale AWS resources.
This is where the
kind of data exists.
actual processing is.
This is a physical
building, a data center.
You do not specify
a data center.
You don't have access to
which, or we don't even
know how many data
centers comprise
of individual
availability zones,
though there are multiple.
Each one is going to have
redundant power, networking,
connectivity.
They're going to be
separate facilities.
And, yeah, tens of thousands
of servers per data center.
Now, importantly, there is a
lot of security considerations
around those.
So each location
is selected to try
to mitigate
environmental risk, which
itself is kind of an interesting
like bigger discussion to have.
That's really not, you know,
this isn't the time for it.
But thinking about
the fact that like
there is some known analysis
happening around which regions
are safest to live
in, or better,
safest to store information,
which I could maybe
translate to safest
to live in as well,
from an environmental
standpoint.
And so AWS is definitely picking
up all that prime real estate,
and all the cloud
providers are, to mitigate
the risk to their data storage.
So that's kind of
one consideration.
They have so many
redundancies within them
to try to reduce any sort
of failures or downtime.
Critical components are
going to be backed up
across multiple
availability zones.
So any sort of the kind of
like core resources of them,
they'll be backed
up automatically.
Caveat with this statement,
that we'll talk about
in the next slide, but,
officially, data center
locations are not
disclosed and there is kind
of no public access to them.
In the event of failures, they
have kind of automated processes
that will kind of transfer the
data across to other regions
quickly so that
they can mitigate
the amount of information lost.
What I find most
interesting, though,
is this kind of
next bullet point
here, in that they
don't use kind
of a single,
standard manufacturer
for the actual physical
servers or any sort of hardware
in that space.
Because if you
think about it, if I
have a single
provider that's like,
hey, Dell produces all of the
servers for AWS's servers.
Well, now I know that if
I'm a bad actor, that all
I really need to do is
penetrate Dell's systems
to embed some sort
of vulnerability
or if I can just identify the
vulnerability in some sort
of existing Dell system,
then I know that I
can hit all of AWS's servers.
So they use equipment
from multiple, different
manufacturers and
actually very explicitly,
they have kind of this layer of
almost shell companies to hide,
in a sense, who is
making the order.
So let's say they're like,
we need some new networking
equipment or some new
high speed cables.
Rather than saying this
order is coming from AWS,
it's going to be some other
company branded around that so
that it's not clear
what all equipment is
going into these data centers.
So there's a lot
of consideration
and thought going
around ensuring
the security and the
reliability of AWS data centers
and really, again,
any cloud platform.
But again, as I said, there
is a caveat with that.
There have been quite
a few data leaks
that have leaked official
locations of AWS data centers.
And this isn't me trying
to put them on blast.
This is just the nature of it.
And for that matter,
too, quite a few
have been identified just
based off of outages.
Again, when all of a
sudden, half of the internet
goes down for, on
a random Wednesday,
and we see that there are
major storms in this one
specific region in
the United States,
then you can probably drill in
pretty quickly and say the data
centers might be over here.
Or, again, hey, there
was a massive fire
at a warehouse in some random
location in northern Virginia.
And also, conveniently, there
were a bunch of outages on AWS
Then I might know that there was
some sort of strong connection
between these.
So there have been a lot of--
you can just search and
find countless examples
of this, where different data
centers have been identified.
So it's just the nature of it.
With the ease of information
spread right now,
or the kind of the
era we're in, there's
no way to completely hide these.
But a lot of steps are taken
to try to mitigate that risk.
I'll say more
interestingly, too,
is the history on kind of cloud
computing development is deeply
intertwined with kind of
our government contracting
infrastructure.
And so there's a really
interesting article
from The Atlantic.
I encourage you to read it.
It's just about why, first
off, AWS, their first region is
northern Virginia, where again,
DC and all the government
contracting locations are.
So an interesting discussion
on why that happened
and kind of how that's
grown out of it.
So, yes, a lot of history here,
a lot of interesting innovation
happening, for very
intentional reasons.
So I encourage you to kind of
get some background on this,
to understand how these
technologies evolved.
OK, a few more kind of, I'll
say kind of vocabulary words
that you might see
throughout this.
AWS often talks about
points of presences,
but really this just consists
of all of their other
like edge locations and
regional edge caches.
So what that means is that, OK,
we have our data centers that
are scattered around,
but also there are these,
think about almost like
smaller data centers that
are cheaper to build.
They can put them up
in many more locations.
And these are designed to
just really minimize latency.
So might make more sense with
an example, here So imagine,
again, I'm Netflix.
That was been our
example for a while now.
Imagine I'm Netflix
and I want to ensure
that we have the absolute
lowest latency for all
of our high quality videos.
I mean, you probably
notice this,
you can be in some
really obscure locations.
Other websites are very slow.
Netflix still seems to be
able to stream really, really
high quality video with
relatively low latency, very
minimal buffering.
And that's because
they're heavily utilizing
these sort of edge caches.
So what they're
saying is, hey, rather
than us storing all of our
videos, all of our movies and TV
shows, in kind of these Amazon
data centers and these broader
regions, we're
going to try to put
them as close to the
customer as possible.
So kind of taking it from
an example perspective,
I'm here in Logan.
I want to go watch, I don't
know, insert random new show
on Netflix.
When I connect to Netflix
or click on this video,
if I was just using kind of the
standard AWS infrastructure,
like we've talked about
with the data centers,
then my request would
have to go to at least
wherever the closest
data center is, which,
let's say it's 500 miles.
And then that has
to come back to me.
And everybody's
hitting that same data
center or that same smaller
set of data centers.
But, again, now imagine
that, or especially
if I'm really kind of far out in
away in the country somewhere,
where I'm not close
to a major city,
it's going to be
really slow latency
or high latency to get that
video out to me quickly.
So instead, what they do,
is they have these edge
caches where they say, let's
put all the movies that we can
or all the TV shows as close
to the customer as possible
so that we can ensure that
they have the lowest latency.
It's going to come at a premium,
because I'm replicating storage
across a bunch of
locations, but I'm
going to make a better
experience for my customer
and they're going to prefer my
platform over other platforms.
And for that matter, too,
I can be creative about it.
If there's a less popular show,
then I can say, hey, maybe
I'm not going to put
that one close to them.
I'm going to predict
what videos are typically
watched in this area.
So I'll just kind of pull
that one back and say,
if they want to watch
it, I'll send it to them.
It might be a little
bit slower, but I'm not
going to waste those
excess resources.
So there's all sorts
of creative ways
that you can structure
these sort of utilizations
of AWS infrastructure.
And so that's why it's important
to know that you have access
to all of these.
You'll see this as well, too,
you've probably noticed like,
for example, if you
pick on a random news
website, your local news, they
might have really long load
times for their videos.
And you're like, how
are you so slow compared
to YouTube, for example?
And that's, again, because
of things like this.
They're not going to be
ensuring that they're
using these regional edge
caches to minimize latency
and all that sort of stuff.
They're like, we're going
to host this on our website.
We have this stored at one data
center on one server somewhere.
And so, therefore,
it's just going
to be slow because
it's not close to you,
and we don't have a ton
of resources spun up
to serve this out.
So recognize this, as you're
starting to browse the internet
or just kind of go about
your daily life, scrolling,
Instagram, TikTok, whatever,
just start to think about what
you're experiencing and
how the kind of back end
might be structured leveraging
some of these resources.
So, again, up to
this point, we've
been talking about the
global infrastructure of AWS
and of cloud providers.
I do want to, again,
address some of these points
and at least give you some food
for thought around them related
to kind of the
implications of that.
And even if these are
robust enough statements
around saying that this is a
truly global infrastructure.
What I mean by that is
if you look at this map
here on the left, each one of
these dots, ignore the colors.
That's just based off of
their existing regions,
or if at this time, when some
of these were coming soon.
And you can see a pattern, a
pretty interesting pattern,
not too surprising.
But these are all of
the regions that we
see for AWS cloud resources.
And they tend to stretch
broadly across the US,
a bunch of Western Europe, you
here through the Middle East,
right through Saudi Arabia,
down across into southeast Asia,
and then onto east Asia.
And you see some as well
on the coast in Australia.
One dot in South Africa.
One dot here would be
probably like Brazil-ish area.
And below, as well, these
are just the edge locations
and like the
regional edge caches,
so kind of those smaller ones.
But they still kind of follow
that same general pattern.
And this is what I mean by
the global infrastructure,
is what we see
actually is that this
is a, or these resources are
typically deployed where you
have higher, not only
population centers,
but also spending power towards
those population centers.
Which, again, that's
no fault of theirs.
That's exactly
what you should do
to kind of minimize your costs
and maximize returns on this.
But it does present a
really interesting effect,
where it's going to be hard.
If I find myself in
sub-Saharan Africa,
it is going to be very
difficult to ensure
that I can build resources
in my region that
serve my customers as
effectively as a company that
is, again, based in
northern Virginia.
And so this is one worry
with cloud resources.
That it does tend to
reinforce patterns of kind
of wealth concentration.
Because, again, it is
a commercial entity.
So they have to make money.
They can't just do things out
of the goodness of their heart.
But it does present an issue.
This funky map here on the right
that I'm showing, actually,
this is highlighting as
well another thing that's
kind of exaggerated from this.
So the outlined
black map, that's
probably most familiar
to you, that's
the mercator
projection of the map.
That's what, this, I'm
pretty sure is mercator.
Don't quote me on
that, but might
be mercator or one of
the other ones that's
slipping my mind right now.
But, anyway, one of the
most common representations
of the map we see.
And what it tries to
do is highlight or kind
of show the shapes of these
nations or of these continents.
But what it does tend to do is
it exaggerates at the poles.
And so you can see
here, for example,
makes Greenland look very, very
large, makes Africa look not too
much larger than Greenland.
What this map on
the right shows,
with kind of this
green outline, is
a map that better represents
the physical landmass
of the countries.
So it looks a little bit
more exaggerated than what
we're used to.
That's because we're
trying to project
a sphere onto a flat surface.
But this more accurately
represents landmasses.
So you can see, when
you kind of, if you
were to overlay the dots
in your head, from this map
onto this green map, you
would see that they actually
fall on even smaller of an
area of the of the world.
So there's a lot of
the world that isn't
served by these resources now.
And it does present some
interesting opportunities,
even from a kind of
monetary perspective,
to serve these resources.
I'd encourage you
to check out some
of these links, a
variety of stories.
This one about, a couple of
these are podcasts as well.
This one about Detroit residents
building their own internet
service.
There are some other interesting
ones like both Facebook's here
and this was an Alphabet
companies project,
but this was to try to
provide internet resources,
or kind of computing
resources, actually,
internet resources specifically,
to under served regions
in the world.
And so they've done this
for a variety of reasons
and using a couple of
different approaches.
But it does present
some interesting kind
of ethical questions around
the global infrastructure
of the cloud that we have today.
So, again, it's all just
to say we have access
to a lot of resources now.
We have, again, with
the caveat of the globe,
but we have basically
access to, I
would say, at least a large
swath of the world's population
via these cloud resources.
I can launch a website today
and push it live in India,
and have it available,
with super low latency,
to most southeast
Asian customers.
So there's a lot of
value and strength
in that, and that is one of
the superpowers of the cloud
that we'll have to learn
how to leverage, if we want
to be most effective with this.
So I'll leave it at that.
Again, like I said, take into
account some of these questions.
Think about this some.
Read slash listen to some of
these articles and information.
And then we'll
catch up next time
and start to dive a little bit
deeper into actually leveraging
some of these resources.
So thanks and have a good one.